Hi I'm Jules
And I'm Julian
And I've been growing my beard for 8 hours (months).
What?!
Minutes!
Hi there follicly challenged friends, Jules
here for Dnews.
Its 2016, and beards have become ubiquitous.
Forcing hundreds of hairs out of the bottom
of your face has almost become a prerequisite
in hip cities like Brooklyn, Portland, or
San Francisco.
But that’s not really fair to everyone who
isn’t like me, and physically can’t grow
a full or thick beard.
As pre-pubescent boys, we lived to hope that
one day we’d be able to rock a giant face
warmer.
We were even counterintuitively told to shave,
so that the hair would come in faster and
thicker.
There are a lot of obvious reasons that’s
not in any way true, but we still optimistically
did it.
Sadly, the fact is, not everyone can grow
a beard, and even those that can have varying
levels of success.
So, is there some trick, or medication, or
just a dang explanation to make up for the
beard variety?
Your first inclination may be to say, “Well,
it’s testosterone and men with more testosterone
grow better beards”.
But that’s not quite right.
Testosterone is part of a group of hormones
called androgens, which regulate sexual development.
Specifically, testosterone regulates, among
a ton of other things, what we call, “male
secondary sex characteristics”.
That covers physical attributes usually associated
with men, but which are not directly involved
in reproduction.
Sure, beards are sexy, but you don’t have
sex with them.
So, testosterone is the reason men (and some
women) have facial hair, more muscle mass,
deeper voices and so on.
But that’s NOT the reason some men can’t
grow beards.
Here’s the tricky part: testosterone levels
on their own don’t predict hair growth;
in fact, the chemical you’re really looking
for is called dihydrotestosterone, or DHT,
which is basically a super potent form of
testosterone that induces both beard growth
and also… hair loss.
And the trickier thing?
Whether or not you can grow a beard, and whether
or not your hair falls out, is determined
almost entirely by the number of androgen
receptors in the upper layer of your skin.
The more androgen receptors you have, the
more DHT will bind to them, and more hair
will appear on the lower half of your head,
and less on the upper half.
The reason that the same chemical causes exactly
opposite results is because there is different
gene expression based on the different types
of hair follicles.
Unfortunately for my beardless or balding
buddies, the number of androgen receptors
you have seems to be ultimately decided by
genetics.
And while there are medications that can lower
the amount of DHT in your body, which is how
some people fight male-pattern baldness, there
is little you can do to boost your number
of androgen receptors to the point where you
turn a baby-face into a lumberjack.
That’s not to say you can’t increase them,
studies show it is possible, it is just unlikely
to have a serious effect on beard growth.
But of course, there are exceptions.
Men with plenty of androgen receptors and
DHT can end up developing alopecia areata,
a skin disease that attacks hair follicles,
and results in large bald patches on the beard
or scalp.
Luckily, it’s treatable.
There are also some women who are able to
growth dark, thick facial hair as a result
of a condition called “hirsutism”.
Just as in men, this can occur if the woman
has too many androgen receptors along with
higher levels of testosterone, which women
already naturally produce in small amounts.
And female facial hair is not uncommon; roughly
5% of women in the US have hirsutism.
But in the end, I’m sorry to say, if you’re
a man in your 20s, and you’re still struggling
to complete the lumberlook, then you’ll
likely be struggling for the rest of your
life.
At least be happy that you probably won’t
go bald anytime soon.
And for those of you who are both scraggly
AND balding, my deepest condolences.
Write your parent’s genetics a strongly,
stronly worded letter.
One thing you can control, however, is how
your beach bod looks.
Beachbody On Demand can help!
Check them out online at DNewsBOD.com, where
you can get access a wide variety of workout
programs including the world-famous P90X,
Insanity, Focus T25, and bunch of others.
Sign up for Beachbody On Demand today and
get a FREE 30-Day Membership.
But maybe you don’t even want a beard.
After all, there’s all kinds of bacteria
living up there.
Trace tells you all about how gross a beard
can be here.
So, what about you?
Does your facial hair follow your family lineage?
Let us know down below in the comments and
make sure to like and subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.